chance to get it back and advance it
they throw in the backcourt to george
and bridges fouls paul george who just
hit two big free throws but he has
missed three tonight
and even if he hits these two that makes
it a three-point game with 8.2 remaining
and they have a timeout to advance the
ball to the front court and we fall so
much in love with scoring in this league
patrick bentley has been outstanding his
energy his effort his enthusiasm
disruptiveness on the defensive end
against booker if the clippers win this
ball game
it has everything to do with what
beverly has done against brooklyn
it has been a tenacious defensive
performance from both teams
huge free throws here for paul george
and that's critical because now if he
hits the second one
sons only needed two to tie it and
they've already given up a free throw
rebound
before you can't assume
beverly's pursuit has to be accounted
for
george who's hit some big buckets down
the stretch
missing that free throw he's got one
more
crowder and ayton along the free throw
lane to make sure they secure it if he
misses another
missed another and the call timeout
paul george misses a pair and the sons
with a chance to win it
with 7.8 remaining
wow
and that was a long rebound bridges did
a great job securing it
[Applause]
7.8 seconds remaining suns to inbound
down by one
crowder has it hooker looking to get
free
into the hands of booker booker against
beverly finds crowder
bridges for three one go ball knocked
out
and it's still sons ball with eight
tenths of a second remaining
according to the official's first call
but of course they're going to go check
it now
which gives well enough more suns ball
if it's it's phoenix's ball they're
going to get a free timeout that they
don't have
this is the fourth review in the last
two minutes
which is a rule that i think should be
changed because the advantage goes to
monty williams
with no timeout or short clock to design
and this is the first time they sent the
double on the perimeter
bridges got a good look
[Applause]
that's a perfect look it just wouldn't
go down
there was man and ayton right there in
there
on who touched it last if the clippers
finish this off
this is the definition of stealing it
when you've been behind the whole game
they found their way back
they got enough clutch plays mark
mentioned it
how well patrick beverly defended his
impact
luke canard coming off the bench for
some
big time fourth quarter points meanwhile
if it's
phoenix ball eight tenths of a second
that's enough time to
catch even turn and shoot with eight
tenths of a second
obviously the execution on how you do it
is critical
for the phoenix sun cousins waving his
arms
not an easy inbound of that big body in
front of you
crowder looking throws it out puts it
down
he puts it down it's over
they're trying to say goaltending but
that's a live basketball he can finish
it
right there is no goaltending on an
inbound pass you can
catch it above the rim
the officials going over to discuss it
there's been bottles being thrown from
the court
but right now the ruling on the floor
was that the basket counted
what a perfectly executed play ayton
guides it in beautifully
what an incredible job by monty williams
designing that play to perfection
but there's time on the clock
and again another great screen by booker
d'andre who was terrific tonight 24
points 14 rebounds
with a bigger shot of his life that's
just a
perfect pass from crowder absolutely
perfect
and just to reiterate there's people in
here saying that's goaltending no
that's a live basketball you can grab it
and finish it you can block it away
that's excellent execution and great
awareness of the rule
so the officials still conferring
there's nothing
a definitive determination that the game
is
[Applause]
this has been such a fun game to watch
obviously the replay is stalling the
momentum but these two teams just
getting after each other and remember
this came off of the free timeout
that monty williams got because of the
previous review
without that review without the free
time out there's no way they get this
type of quality shot
and they don't run this type of play you
can't no
they're going to put more time on the
clock the only thing though is that
the clippers don't have any timeouts
so even if they put three tenths of a
second they've got to throw at the
length of the floor
and then get a shot off quickly catch
and shoot not gonna guard him
and then double and paul george is the
right play
the tomb looking to make the pass
the tomb lobs it up past george has it
george fires away
no good it's over suns win game two
[Applause]
three
the sun's playoff winning streak is now
nine in a row
[Applause]
and not get it off in time as booker and
ayton
with big plays down the stretch this
phoenix suns team and this magical
season continues
meanwhile the clippers another gritty
effort
falls short and they're back in the same
position they've been in the first two
rounds down 0-2
but they've responded in each of the
first two rounds to come back to win the
series
[Applause]
but they've got a tough opponent here of
these phoenix suns